[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
und zu meinem letzten video in diesem
jahr
heute ist der 31 dezember und das jahr
ist leider schon zu ende
arbeit muss sagen es war ein sehr sehr
langes jahr wir haben sehr viel erlebt
und jetzt machen wir heute einen kleinen
jahresrückblick damit ihr unsere
highlights aus dem jahr 2017 sehen könnt
ja nicht chronologisch geordnet ist es
einfach lustig geordnet haben also die
besten szenen rausgesucht die coolsten
events und natürlich die ganzen vielen
outtakes die manchmal rausgeschnitten
werden und manchmal drinnen bleiben
es wird spannend das jahr 2017 hat schon
richtig gut gestartet wir haben nämlich
in diesem jahr die eine million
abonnenten erreicht mein gott ich hab
dir eine million abonnenten erreicht
ist es nicht der wahnsinn millionen auf
youtube krass aber ich sehe keine
kommentare
irgendwie verstehe ich nicht mehr eine
million abonnenten er ist wahnsinnig
eine million und 1 wäre ich jetzt gerade
abonniert hat ist er eine million sky
abonnent ist das der hammer ja als
erfurt block in deutschland haben wir
die eine million abonnenten geknackte
morath wie jüngst ihr dabei wie hast du
das geschafft
ja ich war da kann auf eine messe und du
warst gehört und habe ich kann dem
ausland und es war einfach wir haben ein
mega gefühl ich glaube ich war ja das
war auch deine erste china reise muss
man dazu sagen ja und ich habe zum glück
froh dass er wieder heil zurückgekommen
ist aber es war der hammer so viele
tolle menschen viele vielen dank fürs
abonnieren und war einem mega erlebnis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieses jahr waren wir natürlich auch
viel auf tour wir waren auch vielen
messen wie zum beispiel auf der ifa
messe auf der internationalen
funkausstellung in berlin wo wir
natürlich wie jedes jahr die
innovationen und neuheiten für euch
herausfinden aber auch für uns für
bewerber rar
deswegen sind auf jeden fall vor allem
was die technik im haus angeht das ist
einfach eine messe sondern eine messe wo
man einfach mal hin muss und es war
wirklich am stand wo wir waren von bosch
da war die hölle los
die haben sie sagt es waren noch nie so
viel es war wahnsinn alle umgekippte
frau
da haben wir auch den ralf zacherl
kennenlernte mario kotaska den roland
trettl und wirklich ganz ganz viele
tolle menschen der cast natürlich
carsten dorf das hat super viel spaß
gemacht mit den köchen da sondern
bisschen auch ja die zeit zu verbringen
also das heißt wir sind nächstes jahr
auf jeden fall wieder auf der ifa mit
sicherheit im september
in rostock engagiert
ich denke
dieses jahr waren wir auch mit samira
wieder auf der internationalen
süßwarenmesse man muss dazu sagen soll
mir war zum letzten mal dabei gern
vielleicht will vielleicht aber gerade
mal mit kann genau weil jetzt es ja
schulkind und die süßwarenmesse ist
natürlich für uns immer ein highlight
weil wir da wirklich auch ganz viele
tolle innovationen im bereich der
süßwaren kennenlernen untersuchung
dieses jahr auch wieder da sind wir auch
wieder
[Musik]
fazit popcorn oder bestimmte art fußball
inzwischen einen kredit ich hoffe ich
habe ich plane nicht faul ist
[Musik]
murat
komm du kannst es besser als ich kommt
es auch schon heimgebrauch immer auf in
meinem regal deine mama weiß
nein das ist mein papa machen du bist ja
auch jurymitglied genau ich bin ja auch
im sweet chili mitglied weiter rundschau
mit dem lebensmittelhandel und das ist
wirklich super interessant weil wir dann
zusammen immer abstimmen welches
süßwaren haben haben den
innovationspreis verdient und was gibt's
neues und so weiter also wirklich sehr
interessant da sind wir nächstes jahr
auf jeden fall wieder dabei genau es war
müssen nicht nur ungesund sein
ja das stimmt wir haben in diesem jahr
auch ganz viele videos gedreht ich mein
murat wir drehen dann nicht nur drei
videos in der woche für unseren kanal
wir drehen hier auch ein video alle zwei
wochen für den globus kanal wir haben
jetzt auch videos für den intersport
kamer sz ganz neu besprechen wir gleich
noch an ob januar
wir haben videos gedreht so unserem
neuen kanals um technik kanal das ist ja
auch für mehr innovationen gewesen in
diesem jahr die nasa-mission schleifen
und ich habe ein bisschen schleifen
lassen weil einfach viel dazwischen kam
es kam die vox-sendung dazwischen der
bau und so weiter aber im nächsten jahr
werden es auf jeden fall wieder darum
kümmern und alle technischen fragen zu
produkten zb dorf beantworten
ich muss heute zu sagen wir drehen zwar
sehr viele videos aber wir haben auch
beim dreh immer super viel spaß also ich
glaube es gibt kein thema was so viel
lacht zusammen weint zusammen lacht
zusammen so viel erlebt wie unser thema
inzwischen alle im kreativbereich zimmer
bis zu 15 jedenfalls heißt es hier noch
ein paar ausländer anguckten wir machen
das wenn die helfer nicht krank ist
da das desire z
die ausnahme
so jungs sorry aber ich schlag dich zum
ritter dich zum ober ritter und dich cls
pd
berlinale den film anschaut wie die
preise zu hoch
sorry aber ich muss in die küche gesetzt
das packen jung ganz tolle veranstaltung
ist vorbei foto ddp das aber es gibt
eine abmahnung
also dann nimm du die kids und ich
praktisch brachen ein
du hast jungs auf die lager sind
kompakter machen nein das sieht doch gut
aus hier ist sagte pofalla
gut getroffen
da kann schon mal erzählen wir die
machen wie marmelade schmeckt ja mal
beim titel geholt habe die beatles euch
wie siehst du weißt du wie ich freue
mich dieses glaub ich mir wieder in
salzburg sind ich konnte ja auch so
lustig der nächsten mal zehn schreibt
schlecht mir geht's so gut unterhalten
hatte mich öfter kommen heute macht das
viel besser als ein baum
aber da finden wir wägen die mir helfen
sich der opa natürlich aussendung
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich weiß nachher sagen zuschauer bringen
das machen und meine taschen wurstfinger
im handschuh ich das sowieso kein
gepackt die züchtige strip finger weil
es so sind nicht mehr aus schälen
willst du noch mal sagen dass wirte
haben haben der papa nicht so sehr aber
er ist raus wir haben das video anschaut
damit vielleicht griechenland seine
augen werden jetzt ganz meter
deine augen werden ganz schwer und die
augen die da vor allem zulässt seinen
augen nach die augen werden immer schwer
aber jetzt mal wieder auf
[Gelächter]
so also ich hätte gern dass 50 fuß
sandwich das ist keine 50 30 fuß als das
sind 30 cm 30 cm ist ein sparschwein
ja ich habe gedacht sagt muslims
so jetzt gehen wir nach hause wo retter
den preis ihrem pferd geklaut du hast
nicht geklaut betreut das pferd
das könnte wohl in kürze mehr von auto
und wer clown
du hast nicht gedauert hat sie haben die
klausel soll ich natürlich warum hast du
uns fährt gekümmert stand er alleine
es ist ihm nachgelaufen
dass in einem mit genannt was macht das
eine einmalige sache anders
aber spaß ist aber die sanierer
die hat es nicht einfach damit genommen
noch geklaut nehmen eben nicht die
schlechteste note teig muss ganz lange
kneten
ich hatte übrigens einer der größe l
also ganz große eier da ist übrigens die
größten eier hat chuck norris
[Musik]
ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr möchtet den
rand bestreichen
nur finde ich das immer nicht ganz so
gut denn daran dass so ein bisschen und
bröselig woran wir herrn dich
die menschen
[Applaus]
es ging es also auf der messe natürlich
auch entzückt kaffeemaschine ernsthaft
die hat adhs ernsthaft an den frank wäre
ja und es lag mir natürlich sehr viel
dran noch mal ich warte kurzfilmen
egal was ich mache einfach auf haupt
doch der klingel nicht dass sie zu sehr
ein raus ja es sieht aus wie so eine
gruppe weist du so eine robic zu eine
kleine puppe die in alaska von diesen
gesagt ist echt jetzt ja um nicht
überlebt hat kann es sein das ist
aussieht wieso nicht überlebt hat nein
schaut mal kuchen zu behalten beleidigen
sehr weit hergeholt die robert mit
überlegen murat ist gucken auch kinder
zu und wer möchte kann zum beispiel hier
außenrum noch ein paar essbare blumen
legen das finde ich auch richtig schön
ja sowieso auf gras mit cool ja die
haben gras draußen also zum dekorieren
ja das ist wirklich zum classic ein ganz
einfacher so richtig typischer
geburtstag ja so ungefähr aber was ich
schon mal fragen wollte morath jetzt mit
uns kommen sagt werden einfach zu groß
was da wirklich die behörden können und
warum es ist auch eine kurze damit ich
besser riecht und lassen kann was einen
großen mund dann wirklich die torte
gleich besser vielleicht kann ich damit
den muss steuern kann mir probiert es
mal wieso renten der durch den garten
und und und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und jetzt und da ist jetzt ganz wichtig
dass jetzt nicht komplett 900 gramm
fleisch darin anbraten
denn ansonsten
[Musik]
und ich würde auf jeden fall sagen dass
dieses jahr auch ein jahr der motiv
torten war denn wir hatten viele anlässe
ich habe zum beispiel die dumpfe torte
gemacht für die lisa weil sie in baby
bekommt oder bzw schon bekommen hat
mittlerweile wir haben die game of
thrones torte gemacht
[Musik]
oder zum beispiel auch das einhorn ich
meine das einhorn war ja dieses jahr
wirklich das jahr des einhorns und da
blieb unsere einhorn vater natürlich
nicht aus genauso wie die 100 rolle
was sagst du dazu was man tut und
nächstes jahr soll das flamingo werden
ja wobei flamingo war dieser schon so
ziemlich die letzte haben alle auch
schon wieder um irgendwie war aber nie
solider halt meine freundin hat jetzt
entdeckt lama hast du recht
nächstes jahr wird das jahr des lamas
wir kommen wieder zurück auf die torten
wir haben in diesem jahr zum beispiel
auch oktoberfest orten gemacht wie das
dirndl oder auch die lederhose
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und zum beispiel auch die bosse die
torte das war die erste torte die es in
kürzester zeit auf eine million klicks
geschafft hat das war schon da habe aber
steckte auch sehr viel arbeit dahinter
[Musik]
ja wo wir gerade bei arbeit sind murat
was bereitet uns in diesem jahr am
meisten arbeit ganz furchtbar war dass
der bau also so waren sie dass man hier
alles machen deswegen normalerweise
müssen wir fertig sein wir wollten
einfach ich das video war ja dann wollte
nur eben im januar einziehen mit einem
messer april recht ist sie haben im
april
das erfahre ich jetzt in diesem video
ich glaub's nicht mal gucken ob wir im
jahr 2018 mit dem bau fertig werden dass
es wird auf jeden fall spannend bleiben
die küche haben wir schon fertig geplant
die ist schon mal fix aber alles andere
steht noch in den sternen und ich muss
auch sagen die bau updates videos die
meist geklickten zu sehen eher harmloser
waren es ja ihr könnt ja mal schreiben
das fragen wir auch am ende noch mal
welche videos euch denn am meisten
interessieren was gefällt euch am
meisten spins motiv torten normale
torten ich meine ist schon immer so ich
versuche immer herauszufinden wer mag
war und wir schauen noch immer dass wir
alles schön abdecken können und wenn ich
mal 23 motiv torten mache dann heißt es
gleich aus berlin noch mal wieder
normale torten dann mache ich wieder
normale torten natürlich und versuche es
abwechslung abwechslungsreich wie
möglich zu halten aber irgendwie fühlen
sich manchmal benachteiligt geld ja aber
ich glaube das ist auch gar nicht an
aber ihr könnt ihr mal schreiben welche
themen für euch die interessantesten
sind und auch waren im jahr 2000 sind
also bei abregnen kann rechnet horten er
kochen ja auf jeden fall packen baby
updates fallen raus nein ich bin nicht
schwanger
es war auch eine heiße dass messungen
das war natürlich auch interessant und
wir haben vor im nächsten jahr als ab
morgen einmal monatlich ein back stage
wieder zu machen als auch wechselt
wortspiel
oder wissen sie schnell
und da werden wir einfach gerne zeigen
was ich so einen monat lang mache also
ein bisschen bei dem auch die frage
kommt wie machst du das alles zeitlich
und wie organisiert ihr das mit den
kindern und so weiter und ich denke so
ein bisschen backstage einblicke auch
beim dreh bei sell on tour ist immer
ziemlich interessant ihr könnt ihr
einfach eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreiben
dieses jahren morath muss ich sagen ich
glaub du warst auch ziemlich stolz auf
uns denn wir haben auch preise abgesahnt
wir haben mit dem größten medienpreis
europas gewonnen den medien internet
award der größte internet award die
webby gepolstert versteht schon mal
überleitung nett zu dem video von der
barbara schöneberger also jungs wieder
rein gelegen
jetzt kommt der ausschnitt und von
barbara schöneberger auf der bühne
murat trauma gefällt wir mal gucken wer
es geschafft hat
wir als gewinner vom feld zu gehen es
ist alles weg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hast du uns denn damit gebracht ja das
ist die samira und dies auch schon seit
fünf jahren mit dabei war eineinhalb
jahre alt als ich mit demut channel
angefangen habe hat damals noch lärm
studiert bin grund und
hauptschullehrerin und mir war
anscheinend langweilig neben haushalt
beruf kind ehemann das ist dein kind ist
mein zahn jedoch nicht ausgeliehen
einmalig schönen ihr halte der trend
geht zum eigenen kind wählen und und das
heißt sawatzki mama kocht schmeckt das
wirklich gut oder sie das so toll aus
schmeckt auch gut was kann sie am besten
schokokuchen schokokuchen der
werbefreies war ja schon richtig genial
vor kurzem haben wir auch den axel
springer erwartet mit eingesteckt der
place to be award im bereich food hat
mich auch wirklich sehr gefreut so war
auch lustig gerade freundin und ihren
familien gebracht
ich hab's dir gesagt bietet dank ja ich
mir bieten dank nicht mehr nach
irgendwas anderes
und jetzt könnt ihr mal sehen was ich
dann gemacht habe genau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und du hast jetzt einfach du hast jetzt
einfach seinem referat umgegangen
ich habe einfach dem einlieferer und
hast die schlagzeile in der zeitung ja
wahnsinn ja wohl nicht geplant
die coolsten preis glaube das ist der
preis das ist kein fernsehpreis ist gar
nicht die des landes reis von herzen
ich habe nämlich den engel bekommen den
botschafter engel vom bundesverband
kinderhospiz wir haben eben diesen in
diesem jahr ein buch geschrieben das war
einmal die türkische küche und dann kam
der bundesverband kinderhospiz auch
nicht zu beziehungsweise wir uns kurz
geschlossen
denn ich wollte auch in diesem jahr eine
charity aktion machen
nachdem wir ja letztes jahr für ihr
leider die geldspende gesammelt haben
und das einfach jedem irgendwie ans herz
ging habe ich gedacht wir müssen mehr
menschen helfen und auch vielen menschen
helfen und so habe ich dazu und habe
mich mit dem bundesverband kinderhospiz
zusammengeschlossen und das sally and
friends buch geschrieben in diesem buch
sind viele tolle rezepte auch von euch
ich habe ja auch meine zuschauer um
rezepte gebeten wir fügen race deswegen
friends saillant fans weil es eben auch
eure rezepte sind die von mir
nachgemacht und getestet wurden und der
gesamte erlös von diesem buch geht an
oskar das sorgentelefon und oskar ist
einfach für alle da und ich finde es ist
einfach eine tolle aktion fußball auch
wir haben auch in diesem jahr auf
weihnachtsgeschenke verzichtet für
unsere partner und freunde und haben
einfach gesagt wir verschenken dieses
buch weil es eben auch dem kinder
verband zu gute kommt und dem
bundesverband kindischen wirklich ich
will auf beide bücher ziemlich stolz
dass türkische buch weil einfach ich
türkische wurzeln habe und so ein
bisschen auf meine familiengeschichte
reinschreiben konnte was meine eltern
schon alles geschafft haben in ihrem
leben und das türkische buch ist einfach
auch so ein herzensprojekt aber ich muss
sagen das kinderbuch ich einfach so wo
ich denke mensch da haben viele menschen
was davon und viele sind dankbar dafür
ja echt schön und dank auch an alle die
uns unterstützt haben es kam auch viele
firmen auf uns zu haben das buch gekauft
verlost verschenkt und so weiter erkläre
eigentlich kommen weiterhin geben
genau so ein bisschen zu erwähnen würde
reichen ja so muss man schnell
durchlaufen lassen
ja alles mit geholt nur genau das haben
wir in diesem jahr noch erlebt ein mix
ist genau wie jedes jahr ein buch aber
ist hier die frage
ganz kurz wir haben ja noch nicht
angefangen und her würdet ihr euch zwar
ein typisches buch wünschen oder sie
damals dem bereich backen da so alles
classics zwei türkische pianist u2 oder
was meine idee war
verschiedene grund teile und einfache
rezepte zum backen also so was wie ich
mach ein kapitel hefeteig und basic und
dann kommen zum beispiel zehn rezepte
also ich mach dann 666 rezepte zum
beispiel das auch mal einfacher
backrezepte drin sind wir jetzt zum
beispiel im clasico könnt ihr eure
meinung schreiben und ich bin gespannt
darauf oder player dem vorschlag bereits
vorschlag dass wir unser neues buch
männer waren ideen aber es wäre toll
wenn von euch was kommt
bad buchau zwei zutaten es kann zu
machen und so zur strabag und dann
einfach so zwei rezepte dazu dass
deutschland mit 1 oder murat was war ein
weiterer riesenschritt für uns in diesem
jahr so us oder bei schimpansen nach
unten habe ich ganz vergessen boxt
unsere vox sendung war ein großer
schritt für uns und vor allem war es
enorm viel arbeit aber wir haben enorm
viel spaß gehabt also es war wundervoll
ich hatte vier kinder bei mir zu gast
sarah war da dominik warta oliver und
die cosima und ich hatte mit jedem
einzelnen kind eine richtig wunderschöne
zeit wir haben drei tage zusammen
gebacken und dekoriert ich habe die
kinder kennen lernen dürfen bzw die
jugendlichen und dann durfte eben ein
besonderer mensch überrascht werden und
ich glaube man sieht im fernsehen gar
nicht so immer wie viel arbeit
dahintersteckt mädels menschen das netz
dass die menschen einfach
selbstverständlich ist ja es ist einfach
so die man bekommt alles umsonst und das
ist alles so einfach aus
die arbeit dahinter meistens sich hinter
allem was machen mit den brötchen kauft
für 20 cent sie arbeite ich da hin
50 cent wie auch immer und ist dass ich
bisschen schade für uns war das alles
neu und vor allem wir haben alles selber
gemacht hast du in unserer kirche mit
meinem kamerateam labbadia françois
marque marios also waren wir wirklich
alle aus meinem team hammer experiment
von wahnsinn und jungs echt total
unterstützt und stand uns auch zur seite
wenn wir auch fragen hatten und das war
echt die haben uns einfach freie hand
gelassen wir durften drehen wie wir
wollten genau und es war richtig toll
und nächstes jahr machen wir dann in 20
15 sendung ist geplant
es war in der neuauflage von wetten dass
mit mir mit nochmals jahres werden dass
der patient der schlag den raab den
nobodys schwierigkeit morath muss ich
sagen weit dieser traumhafte mora
zuschlagen wasserschlachten murat was
bei der sendung natürlich eine richtig
große herausforderung war als ich habe
auch viele kommentare gelesen
viele fanden sendung toll manche fanden
es zu lange meinte zu kurz und es ist
natürlich schwierig eine krasse motiv
torte innerhalb von 45 minuten zu zeigen
die geschichte vom kind zu erzählen ein
gespräch mit dem kind dafür etwas über
den menschen herauszufinden da
überrascht wird und so viele einzelne
schritte alles in 45 minuten auch wieder
zu geben dass die sendung informativ und
unterhaltsam ist also schon war schon
eine große aufgabe muss ich sagen wir
haben uns halt die aufgabe schwer
gemacht und habe gesagt ja wir müssen
jetzt jede torte muss einbrecher werden
und war schon schwierig geld ja also ich
könnte auch mal als jetzt reinschreiben
was 5 format würdet ihr euch wünschen er
alles gibt ein genauer was haben gibt es
auch nie machen würden es ist
jury-mitglied irgendwo zu sein hat mir
auch schon angebote aber ich wollte das
nicht mehr kein jurymitglied kann gar
nicht bewerten müssen ob jemand gut oder
schlecht gekocht und gebacken hat weil
ich finde kochen backen muss spaß machen
sollte unter keinem zeitdruck stehen und
unsere mitbürger kein wettbewerb also
web überhaupt fliegt raus
obama fliegt grammatik grau es kein
schwarz weiß weiner
den leuten station fliegt raus ja also
es ist nicht alles einfach also
vielleicht habt ihr eine idee den formal
was würdet ihr euch für den fernseher
wieder haben ja gesagt sie würden
weniger motiv taten sehen normales
banken ja wäre auch super oder lifetime
dopen oder sogar gerne machen möchten
morath ihnen im jahr 2018 live packen
das heißt wir haben es auch auf youtube
die möglichkeit live mit euch zu backen
so wie damals bei der galileo sendung
ich kann ich dann vor hat die zutaten
bekannt geben wir machen eine uhrzeit
aus und dann könnt ihr live mit mir
packen ihr könnt mir fragen stellen also
ein ganz normales youtube-video nur eben
in echtzeit und ihr könnt dann eure
fragen stellen und wir beantworten sie
ja das ist richtig toll ich glaube
morath mein großes highlight in diesem
jahr war auch die einschulung von
unserer tochter samira die jetzt schon
sieben jahre alt ist wie sie hier zur
schule und ich kann es einfach nicht
glauben ich habe das gelesen haben
morgen zur arbeit ja und jetzt gemalte
schon im dezember sie kann schon lesen
und schreiben und es ist der wahnsinn
wie schnell kinder wachsen
die hat sie kennengelernt da war sie
gerade mal zwei jahre alt hat ihre
schoko pudding nummer 8 des videoclips
zeigen des orts angekommen das war
wieder so eine überleitung tschuldigung
[Musik]
was heute einen schokopudding und zeigst
du uns wie das geht
rühren sollen wir das gleich mal machen
ja okay und wie heißt du ach prinzip hin
zu mehr zeigt mal den namen auf der
schürze bin super unterkaka ofen brot
das darfst du hier weiter
und jetzt muss man auf den herd rumpf
erstellen damit es nicht an
[Musik]
und wenn es dann tochter ist das voting
party cookies ja ganz schön dick
unglaubliche worte ja und jetzt ist sie
schon ein großes schulklassen
kindergarten und da war natürlich
einschulung in diesem jahr für uns ein
mega thema aber sehr schön da die augen
sind glasig
ja weil ich war emotional wird wenn ich
sehe dass die kinder so groß werden
wird ein buch hat natürlich die
zuschauer hat sie mich gemieden
ich weiß es nicht sagt ich glaube dass
war unser jahresrückblick als ich glaube
wir haben kein highlight vergessen
ich hoffe wir haben muss vergessen wir
haben bestimmt was vergessen aber das
war jetzt man so die zusammenfassung und
ja ich hab österreich österreich genau
wir waren ja das ist ja auch in
österreich auf der messe in wels hat
voll eingeschlagen und und das waren wir
in salzburg bei interspar im europark
beim die herzlich willkommen so serries
welt und münster die idee und wir machen
gemeinsam hat einen super coolen eine
super geschichte erhielt kate kate wir
haben hier fünf bizkit böten drinnen mit
nachricht ist leckeren orangenmarmelade
und einer italienischen buttercreme
dieser koch und hat eben europark dort
einmal bakery und einmal die delicious
und wir haben jetzt eine kooperation mit
intersport da gibt es eben jetzt auch
unsere produkte und wir werden auch
deswegen nächstes jahr öfter sehr offen
weil das immer so liebe die erste reihe
bei jedem gewinnspiel sind die
österreicher die nacht hat steuerlichen
gründen wie die schweizer ja sowieso die
haben sind immer ein paar rechtliche
gründe auch aber jetzt will ich in
österreich durch gestattet wenn ich sie
auch weiterhin machen er die
österreichische richtig cool und richtig
jahr allein auf das signierstunde
im intersport ist the hammer wie viele
menschen da waren und es war so schön es
hat so ein herzliches volk also wirklich
der hammer ich bin jedes mal begeistert
wenn ich in österreich bin und deswegen
werden wir natürlich in diesem jahr auch
oder nächst ja auch wieder nach
österreich reisen im januar
jetzt also murat das war unser
jahresrückblick ich hoffe du begleitet
mich im nächsten jahr auch durchs jahr
doppel scheinwelt zu teuer so was sagt
man das ok ok brauchst du nicht
begleichen glaube nicht dass mich jemand
erschießen oder irgendwas ja und ich
hoffe dass uns der ausbau fertig wird
und ja ihr könnt ja mal einfach sagen
was eure highlights in diesem jahr waren
auf unserem kanal wo das wasser dürfen
ja vielleicht auch ganz ehrlich man muss
immer eine coole konstruktive kritik
ich kann mir noch besser sie müssen sich
kritisieren des jahres das muss ich mal
sagen ja aber echt aber er hat er keins
auswischen ja also ist aber wir können
jetzt einfach schreiben hey vielleicht
was jetzt toll fanden
das wird was wir gerne noch mehr sie
bekennt technik videos auf jeden fall
aber würde sind eure wünsche mehr
myvideo es ist 18 bauen mit murat er
wurde dann öfter irgendwo was bauen oder
neues format für die tänze sind also bis
format 1 definitiv verändert ein anderes
ja also gib mal ein paar vorschläge
also ich wünsche euch jetzt alles alles
gute fürs neue jahr gleich noch ein paar
letzte lustige bilder und ich freue mich
schon aufs nächste jahr wird euch bis
bald türme pastorius wachstumskurs gut
rein morath schuldenstreit schöner gruß
an die österreicher gewarnt haben läuft
ja ja ja die flasche hintergrund ist
eine produktplatzierung oder
[Gelächter]
bisschen besser der wiesentaler was er
wisse der wiese wasser das läuft bei uns
und am friedhof durch aber schnell gut
schmeckt gefunden viele mineralstoffe
los jungs ist ja eigentlich auch falla
mir bist du schwanger
ich habe noch nie aufgefallen dass sich
diese themen hemd noch nie an hatte
zwischen karohemd ich habe das in meinem
schrank entdeckt oder gar daran alte
nein das ist echt hatte sony angenommen
das merke ich mir gut fangen wir an
[Musik]
dreimal
annika lykke li halte die idee
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer
heute ist für mich ein ganz ganz
besonderen moment und zwar war gestern
das bowling spiel zwischen schavan und
der rest der welt und shaban hat
gewonnen
das ist schade dass besondere ja das
besondere am schabbat ist dass schavan
ist der geborene looser hat noch nie in
seinem leben etwas gewonnen er hat in
seinem leben noch nie etwas erreicht
sogar seine eltern haben ihn versteckt
weil sie sich die ihnen geschämt haben
und ich hab mir gedacht habe du hast
diesen pokal verdient
der pokal ist genauso groß bild passte
seine ganzen masse hinein und deswegen
hat der sharan verdient diesen pokal zu
gewinnen
dass er auch mal in seinem leben
erfolgserlebnis hat ich gratuliere dir
von herzen
ich bin zwar eine ehre von einem affen
im pokal herein zu willkommen vor allem
auch noch von einem sprechenden affen
sind vielen dank
[Musik]
juni
hallo liebe freunde von sally partie der
kinderliedermacher wünscht euch alles
gute im neuen jahr
[Musik]
jetzt dreht sie komplett durch die erst
nach silvester kurz ausrichten möchte
martin und
auch noch nie ein super super gutes
neues jahr bleibt gesund und uns wohl
gesund
[Musik]